alter krass das war so was von
lastminute alter servus kids von
herzlich willkommen zur ersten folge
minecraft in 1080p es müssen 1080p seine
ich spiele mich jetzt gerade zum ersten
mal im vollbildmodus und ich musste auch
gerade ein bisschen meine facetime
zurechtrücken
damit das passt und ich habe irgendwie
das gefühl dass ich mein gesicht
irgendwie seltsam verstaucht habe dass
es jetzt länger ist oder verformt in
irgendeiner art und weise deformiert
schreibt mal in die kommentare ob ich
mich irgendwie im gesicht verändert habe
in der art und weise in der das nicht
sein sollte also habe ich irgendeine
fest immer noch richtig oder nord das
war ganz gut zu wissen ich kann es nicht
beurteilen ich glaube so grob passen
also ich hab mich jetzt weder in den
schreck verwandelt noch ins länder man
also ansicht passt dass wir spielen hier
übrigens mein kräfte jam blick wie das
seht und ja die situation ist jetzt eine
lustige und zwar habe ich mein mikro in
der ganzen position das ist sehr lustig
aha und darüber hinaus ist es echt
komisch so einem fall bildschirm zu
spielen das habe ich vor noch nie
gemacht also ich mach das jetzt gerade
ich zum ersten mal
und das ist ja schon mal die einzige
möglichkeit um echte 1080p videos zu
machen
die fest kein bisschen zurecht rücken
immer die gleichen in ruhigen momenten
kann es gebrauchen können wir das
gebrauchen gibt immer das hier
ich glaube das ist echt die einzige
möglichkeit um echte 1080p videos zu
haben weil sonst wenn man hat nur im
fenstermodus aufnimmt und jetzt nicht
gerade in 4k monitor hat dann ja hab
meinem fenster modus immer 720p das ist
ja nicht dass in der sache passt die ich
glaube die facebook passt aber ich bin
ein bisschen seitlich links rechts
werfen recht
bis gestöhnt für alle weiblichen fans
ich bin wieder gut auf drogen bin ich
natürlich nicht leute ich bin doch
absolut beruf und durch china das ist
neuer park und ich bleib einfach in der
luft stehen
genau wie in diesen cartoon film die die
charaktere einfach so über eine schlucht
oder nehme über irgendein klippe
hinauslaufen so merkte ich kann zwar
kontrollrat irgendeine luft laufen aber
sehr doch kein boden unter mir so ging
mir das gerade nur dass ich keinen
karton charakter bin und nicht dafür
einfach ziemlich selbst mag als ob ich
mich für sowas hassen würde hier sicher
nicht okay gut wie kurzes kurzer check
wie sich die lage hier
wir können hier mal den darf anziehe
manchmal ganz nackig so sehr schön läuft
doch eigentlich ganz gut wir sind aber
tatsächlich nicht so weit im bowling
oder für der vorname ist ein bisschen
ein bisschen zulegen jetzt gerade mal so
es ist nämlich echt nun gewöhnen
ungewohnt also ist eine ganz andere
sache man dass minecraft bild in voller
wonne vor sich hat also wenn minecraft
den ganzen bildschirm ausfüllt ist
einfach ganz anders ich bin es gewohnt
dass dahinter in ihrem browser blinkt
oder dass irgendwas anderes passiert
zumindest ein weißer hintergrund jetzt
ist minecraft hat so komplett da meine
ypsilon sieht es auf jeden fall an
meiner glaube ich also meine haut da
unten ist winzig klein geworden jetzt
auf 1080p bild die können wir wieder
größer machen
falls euch das interessiert dass man
eine größere hotmail macht könnt ihr das
ja auch mal rein schreiben
ich habe nur irgendwie ich weiß gar
nicht wie ich das gemacht habe weil ich
gesagt ich hab ihr hobby so gemacht dass
ihr ein 720p aufnahmen ganz gut passt
und wenn ich jetzt in 1080p so hin dass
es da wieder gut aussieht und ich bin
irgendwie merkte 1080 meint ich gehe
zurück dann könnte das ziemlich scheiße
aussehen scheibenkleister schreiben
gleich druck wäre jetzt kurz an die
zeiten zurück verfallen war für meine
mutter mir verboten hat
das wort scheiße zu benutzen aber okay
das ist ein anderes thema so was haben
wir hier das wegwerfen sagt zack zack
zack stiefmutter die ruft auch gerade um
ich bin ich wieder bei meiner familie
für alle die es nicht wissen
und ich bin gerade bester dabei helfen
dieses modul richtig zeitraubend ja
genau deswegen weil man hier am anfang
so diese zwei springer die an sich
eigentlich in ordnung sind
man muss halt auch was machen wir jetzt
hier das irgendwie so viel zu kurz das
wird sich voll falsch an genau genau
deswegen ich lande immer so auf dem
äußersten punkt weil sie viel zu kurz
anfühlen
also das ist eine ganz komische länge
diese sprünge die sowie nicht zu kurz
nicht zu lang sein was man nicht nicht
zu kurz zumal man nicht lang genug dass
es irgendwie lange sprünge sind und ich
kurz genug dass es wie kurze sind das
ist eine ganz komische entfernung so
jetzt immer viel vor bei den hout module
wir gehen ja erstmal mit diesen weißen
parcours weiter okay dass unser erstes
buch das ist nicht schlecht
das wunderbare ist leute ich nehme es
gerade auf ich sage euch erstmal an
welchem datum mich aufnehmen oder auch
nicht weil es gar nicht einsehen kann
weil ich habe auf meinem linken
monitoren das datum und da ich mal kurz
in folge spiele kann ich nicht mehr
unten rechts sehen auf dem linken
monitor wo das datum steht denn auf dem
linken monitor ist auch minecraft
vollbild logischerweise aber lass mich
raten ich glaube heute ist der 21 juli
schreibt man die kommentare wenn ihr das
ihr seht wahrscheinlich weiß ich es auch
aber wurde weiß ich nicht ich glaube ich
mir die videos dann einfach randy moss
im urlaub öffentlich nicht produzieren
nämlich für den urlaub vor ob sie
zusammen mit lud nämlich ein special und
mart wir wollten es eigentlich nicht
mitnehmen aber dann hatten wir so viel
mitleid mit ihm
der schweizer wir hatten so viel mitleid
hat gesagt okay wenn du die chance
nehmen wir dich mit
aber nur dann an jetzt sehr schön und
ich würde sagen und weiter und einfach
durch aber ja wollte nicht sein vor ich
hab diesen parcours glaub ich auch noch
nie geschafft
genau weil diese sprünge so richtig
tricky sind von denen gibt es zwei einen
hier ganz am anfang und ein ganz am ende
und da muss man echt ganz raus laufen
das ist tricky und ansonsten ist er auch
nicht leicht aber ja ihr seht übrigens
auch leute natürlich dass ich hier
hinten das umfeld bisschen verändert hat
normalerweise habe ich ja direkt hinter
mir
diese weiße wand jetzt bin ich hier bei
meiner familie und einem keller
ich bin jetzt hier kern erkennt und da
habe ich das nicht ob man das passiert
mir das mache ich bleibt jedes mal da
hängen so ärgerlich ist wiederum eine
minute acht wir haben auf jeden fall
noch mal versucht sind auch platz eins
ich glaub ich hab einfach asian
sensation
klingt ein bisschen wie ein porno name
klingt wie bislang
das ist mein vorname aber ja sehr schön
so habe ich hier den sprung nice gepackt
nice das habe ich sonst nie und jetzt
bitte bitte bitte bitte bitte
nein ich schaff's wahrscheinlich nicht
wo ich will jetzt ganz einfach fast in
der aufnahme aus dem stimmt gekippt
alter später also nein nicht aus dem
studio mit dem studio sondern hinten
kippt bei jungen ein mann ärgerlich dann
schaffe ich den partnern der ist echt
tricky man aber jetzt kriegen jetzt mal
eine chance vielleicht wenn ich jetzt
einfach jolo durch renne ich kann
natürlich first drive ja
junge ich habe gefühle nicht alter krass
das war so was von lässt mit alter und
ich habe zum ersten mal das modul
geschafft jungen 1 da kann ich dann gut
schlafen stark alter labrador scheiß
drauf jetzt machen aber nochmal komplett
biologisch jetzt geht andere geht es auf
mich darüber dass wir den weg
ok dann haue ich direkt soll jetzt muss
ich raus auf gottes wird nichts das wird
nicht das wird nicht das wort nein sagt
man ich mein leben hat mich mein leben
ich will mit drei leben dieses match
machen wo junge alter schwierig für euch
das war echt meine knappste jump league
runde gerade eben das jump'n'run alter
schwede heiße sache junge okay kann
wir können auch kostenlos essen kurz mal
recken haben halt hier unser stein
schwert das ist an sich nicht schlecht
aber es auch nix dolles unsere acht
rüstungs punkte diesen schon eher gut
für mich
mit das besser so bekomme ich komme hier
jetzt mal hier mitnehmen sagt es wird
kölliker hatte mich stellen habt es wird
ein bisschen körniger bis gefühl hier
sitzt da rechts meine gtx 260 struggled
ein bisschen scheiße jetzt kann ich hier
auf jeden fall dieses dm nicht mehr ohne
kilwi spielen aber ganz ehrlich das ist
auch kein drama
das war so cool dieser jumper co am ende
dieser jumper kur war mein leben
ja es wird ein bisschen körner kurz mal
machen wir kommen um auf die fes schon
okay also 100 fps gerade es ist
tatsächlich bisschen könig hatte wer
jetzt noch mal den kampf gehen auch noch
mal die apps an
dann drucken nämlich schon ich habe das
gefühl es wird ein bisschen aber ganz
recht ist es jetzt ein luxusproblem
ich hätte aber wirklich nicht gedacht
dass eine gtx 760 mit minecraft im
fullscreen problem hat ihr könnt mir mal
rein schreiben wenn ihr auch die gtx 760
und full screen erfahrung damit hat das
normal ist oder ob mein confixx
irgendwas nicht stimmt jetzt mach ich da
war die polizei da sind wir nämlich
jetzt ja 50 fps schon mal wechselt ihr
euch ab
was mit dem nt gebärdet jetzt es ist
tatsächlich körnig krass hallo kannst du
mir mal einer getroffen werden ja er
kann nämlich recken dass der unterschied
ist ich hatte dirigent dadurch dass ich
in ein geklatscht haben roboter von ich
so gut gelaufen aber man muss man das
nach wie vor richtig kritik also die
events zwei punkte gibt immer in
minecraft spiel die ich unbedingt
verbessern wir den instrumenten movement
und meine taktik also meine meine ruhe
quasi im spiel das ich bin ein hitzkopf
ich sage heute ich sehe da einfach rot
und rändern voll drauf um eine angel
erwischt gerade nicht ziel dieses gefühl
aber wir holen uns den spätestens hier
vorne ist eine sackgasse soll jetzt die
wir durch nice und erstaunlich kurz
neben kurzen kopfnicken
da muss ich ihn erwischt hallo ist da
jemand hallo nice feile diaz und
crafting bensch das heißt es gibt ein
schwert für uns junge dieser runde wie
geil alter schwede
erst vollkommen random und dann so ein
geiler abschluss jetzt haben die dfb elf
weiter ohne bis ich bin zwar eigentlich
19 jahre alt und sollte mich nicht wie
ein kleines kind verhalten aber wirkt
das bereitet mir grad schon ziemliche
freude diese wunde
alter schwede das ist komplett crazy und
wie ich halt so bin da stelle ich mich
wieder rein und dann ich habe schon
öfters gesagt okay heißt der gibt mir
erst mal feiert er hat aber ich meine
die schweiz gesehen hab ich das gesehen
das ist glaube ich nicht gesehen jetzt
wird sie nicht ankommen uns gibt's was
auf die backen
zack so nicht schlecht gemacht von ihm
ihr norm freizugeben mikroökonomie co
mirco so nicht schlecht von ihm aber das
reicht einfach nicht also ich hab acht
rüstungs punkte und erschwert da muss er
hat hätten nur einen stein schwert er
muss ein bisschen mehr machen aber er
hat mich immerhin runtergezogen auf 5
herzen da vorne ist der nächste gegner
den holen wir uns da wird es wieder ein
sehr sehr schönes deathmatch zwar nicht
mit null toren aber dennoch eine ganz
entspannte angelegenheit finde ich so
jetzt hör jetzt konnte ich mir bis auf
mesut und ich hab da hätten den gegner
gesehen
ich habe immer alle weg wochen warum
habe ich meine angel weggeworfen und
wann nein wir können nicht sorry sorry
nicht ärzten jetzt jakic colada und
damit vollkommen entspannt ist walter
was ich kann ihn nicht hätten zunächst
jetzt nein ich stelle jetzt nochmal not
gonna happen sehr schöne rede arbeitet
ab ich gehe jetzt nicht noch mal drauf
ja okay wir können jetzt bisschen regen
das ist kein ding vielleicht hier mal
kurzem tnt
da wo ich gerade so rief die aus dem
handgelenk tnt blazon ja das
offensichtlich hat er kommen sehen und
gehört aber gut jetzt können wir nicht
ja er bleibt uns tragen wir regen nicht
mehr
der spielt nicht schlecht aber ich will
dieses thema erstmal zu ende bringen es
dauert schon zu lange ehrlich gesagt er
will uns jetzt hat man dieses eine leben
abluchsen oder macht er nicht verstehen
wenn ich mal was sagen ernsthaft ja
ernsthaft
absolut ich meine ernte lucia wen and
solutions
wer wie ich einfach nicht recht warum
dreckig nicht schrecken ich guck mal
haben die juli an ausgestellt haben wir
die normale die reguläre video in
ausgestellt oder was ist gerade los ich
weg nicht leute seht ich hab jetzt schon
die ganze zeit voll hunger köln nicht
regel nicht schreibt man vielleicht nur
noch durch die region die man bekommt
also durch den video effekt immer
jemanden tötet das war krass sondern
könnte nochmal ab die kurz und jetzt
zeigt er es noch einer da sehr schön
wunderbar und damit haben wir tat sich
die huskies gemacht sehr schön dieses
match beendet und ja ich weiß gar nicht
ist es wirklich so dass man nur noch mit
video nacht kills regeneriert seltsam
also die hunde haben sie scheinbar weg
gestellt
weg mit dem iconia einer person pro aber
am ende habe ich das ding aggressiv noch
gedreht sehr schön heute wenn euch die
folge gefallen hat dann lassen daumen
nach oben da wir sehen uns beim nächsten
video haut rein mach's gut und